foreign
[Music]
goal is to hack the computer behind the
window
okay this is an imaginary window we like
Lars lontria
let's pause here and zoom in we can see
that the Drone has a hacking device on
it now let's get into the details
how is all this going to hack the
computer
oh
gear was created by the sum
sub-verification platform but more about
some stuff in a bit first let's figure
out why drones are needed for this hack
in the first place drones can quickly go
where people cannot
say those are well secured perimeter a
drone can pass through any of the
defenses meant to keep people out it can
fly up to any floor of a building
quickly and often without detection
drones are small so they can even fly
into an open window and wreak havoc on
computer systems in the blink of an eye
but what kind of Wireless technology
would enable a drone to do so much
damage without running out of battery
well there are some zero click attacks
which take just a few seconds this means
that the Drone won't need to pause its
flight the attack can be performed on
the go there's one well-known extremely
widespread vulnerability built into
hundreds of thousands of Wireless mouses
and keyboards that can be taken
advantage of in just one to two seconds
with maximum effect giving hackers
wireless access to a PC and it's called
Mouse Jack
imagine you're sitting at home or
working at an office on one of the top
floors of a building or deep inside some
highly secure facility a few hundred
meters away from a checkpoint
you'd think you're completely safe from
hackers yet here comes a drone hovering
just outside your window
you might notice it or you might not
either way the Drone will install
malware onto your computer in just
seconds
you're unlikely to notice any changes to
your computer and even if you see that
backdoor installer that comes up for a
second you're probably not going to
think that it has anything to do with
the Drone that just flew by and if
you're not at home and instead say at
some office building then the hacker can
find their way into the internal Network
just a few minutes after a successful
attack the bad guys can test several
different exploits on the main servers
of your company it's quite likely that
your company's internal infrastructure
will be compromised before the security
team can even get their eyes on the
breach the attack seems like something
out of a hacking themed movie or video
game where the Drone completes the
attack in just seconds the vulnerability
here is that there's a large number of
wireless adapters but things like mouses
and keyboards and they use a separate
radio channel that doesn't check the
sources of the signals that come its way
unlike Bluetooth these devices aren't
standardized producers on the wireless
Market don't always develop their own
devices and instead use various chips
and the vulnerability here is a chip
called
nrf24l which has an unsafe wireless
radio interface the chip turns out to be
highly popular and is used by a lot of
producers including Dell Logitech
Microsoft HP Amazon gigabytes and Lenovo
and it's really difficult to pin down
exactly how many devices use this chip
this list contains just a few of the
devices that have this vulnerability
physically what happens is the radio
channel on the nrf24l chip uses the same
frequency as Bluetooth and Wi-Fi but
uses only 83 frequencies that are one
megahertz in width which therefore
covers everything between 2400 and 2483
megahertz what happens on a software
level is that every wireless device has
its own Mac address
all these devices work in a star or
bespoke Hub Network there are some
devices like a mouse or keyboard in this
network the nodes and there's a USB
adapter in the middle which is like a
central switch this way each device is
connected directly to the switch however
they are not connected to each other so
the switch is the server and the devices
are the clients therefore the clients or
devices send information about things
like movements of the cursor or keyboard
inputs and the USB adapter tells them
whether the signal was received this
essentially creates a one-way
Transmission in our case the adapter is
connected to a mouse and keyboard
for a real world attack the hacker needs
to figure out and Forge the needed radio
signal
the adapter doesn't broadcast any signal
packs even if they've just been
connected and therefore it's impossible
to determine if there aren't any working
mouses or keyboards every device widely
transmits signal packages to the network
with a unique Mac address the adapters
only pick up signals from their own sub
networks the attack doesn't Target the
MAC address of the adapter but instead
those of the connected devices so for
the attack to work there needs to be a
mouse or keyboard connected in reality
the vulnerability isn't quite the mouse
or the keyboard themselves but rather
their wireless adapters
picking up the signal from a connected
mouse or keyboard which contains the MAC
address backers can forge the signal
using the intercepted Mac address as the
source a vulnerable wireless adapter
won't be able to tell the Hacker's
signal apart from a legit signal and
will enable the keyboard inputs sent
over the compromised radio signal it's
worth noting an interesting and
dangerous fact an adapter from a
wireless mouse can pick up wireless
keyboard inputs the OS in a mouse and
keyboard use related hid devices the
attack works by forging wireless mouse
or keyboard signals to send inputs to
the victim computer which if executed
give hackers access to that computer in
fact these exact keyboard inputs can be
executed at an extremely high rate of
speed 1 000 inputs per minute
however through a successful attack
about 40 to 50 inputs is enough in other
words all that's needed is a few seconds
obviously mousetrack isn't the only
scheme being used for account takeover
hi I'm Lucas from Samsung and as we've
seen fraudsters are growing at an
exponential rate in their ability and
techniques and sophistication to steal
your personal information and break into
your accounts this is due in part to the
rise of AI and now essentially anyone
can become a hacker with the use of
these tools and systems that's why it's
so necessary to have a robust anti-fraud
solution to protect both your business
and the reputation of your business our
solution combines several Technologies
to provide a holistic compliance
solution this could be anything from our
transaction monitoring email phone
verification anti-fraud and pixel
analysis Technologies to find out more
just click the link below to get in
contact with the thumb sub
representative and we'll be able to help
you leverage our system to protect your
business in the future thank you very
much
[Music]
to forge a radio signal hackers need a
device containing an nrf24l chip for
example this could be the Logitech
u-0007 Universal USB adapter however
this adapter Works in a very narrow
radius of about one to two meters
there are some other devices including
the crazy radio PA USB adapter which is
used as the controller for the crazy
file indoor drone this device can
amplify the signal increasing the radius
of attack by up to 10 to 15 meters
however what can be done if the target
is two to three floors above ground or
deep inside a guarded perimeter that's
where the Drone comes into play
modern drones have enough power to carry
things like GoPros or higher capacity
batteries and typically this is enough
to carry a third or even half of the
drone's own weight in this case the
Drone needs to carry a couple of devices
to make the attack happen the crazy
radio PA and its antenna weigh just 12
grams
the second component can be a mini
Raspberry Pi zero which weighs just 10
grams
a battery is also needed for instance
any 3.7 volt battery should do
most single ball computers can be
powered by a 5 Volt or 3.3 volt no
special devices are needed to do this
the battery can be connected directly to
the Raspberry Pi using contacts 1 and 9
gpio if 5 volts is used a DC to DC
mt3608 high voltage computer board is
needed which needs to be connected
through contacts 2 and 9 to gpio however
it'll take some work to solder the
converter here
[Music]
the battery can be charged through a
soldered micro USB for more convenience
and better visualization of the attack
LED indicators can be used instead of a
screen display which takes up too much
battery power and adds extra weight most
single board computers use gpio pins
which use low voltage just enough to
power LEDs
so to turn an LED that's connected to
say pin 26 on or off the following OS
commands need to be executed on the
computer board
in total a 5 volt setup would weigh just
61 grams basically any drone can handle
this kind of weight it's not that
important which exact drone is used
since all it needs to do here is
transport the device a sinner whoop with
a protective frame around the propellers
could work
[Music]
since this attack requires a lot of
flying in close quarters a precise
controller is a must which makes fpv
drones appropriate here however the most
important element here is drone flying
skills
foreign
radio PA board is not able to work in
the attack mode before upgrading
after upgrading the adapter can be used
to send keyboard inputs to work with the
upgraded adapter a small python script
can be used
since the attacker doesn't know the Mac
addresses of the targets they have to
attack what comes up on the broadcast
which is why the autopone flag is used
to visualize the attack using LEDs we'll
slightly modify the jacket script
[Music]
where the LED is the executed script
with the following
[Music]
now the green LED shows that the script
began its attack and the Drone can fly
to its Target the yellow LED will light
up when devices are being searched for
and the red LED will light up when a
device is being attacked the attack is
dangerous due to the ability to transmit
malicious inputs but which command does
that hacker use to get wireless access
the hacker needs a very brief command
that's already built into the victim OS
which can download and activate a
backdoor program in one go it's
important to note a radio channel is
used which means that there can be
interference so the longer the command
the greater the chance that certain
inputs don't get through and all it
takes is One Missed input for the entire
commands to go unrecognized in order to
download and open the file that enables
remote control the hacker uses a command
rather than a graphical user interface
for Windows the command is msie xec and
here's how a short attack sketch could
look like
nowadays any OS can work with a wireless
mouse or keyboard which means that the
commanded attack has cross-platform
functionality giving it the ability to
Target any OS let's look at Windows MSI
is an executable files format generally
used for installation it can be
generated using the popular hacker
framework Metasploit
after the command is executed on the
victim PC the hacker gets access to the
OS control panel on their server This
Server can be anonymous and paid for in
crypto which means the hacker doesn't
leave a trace then the hacker can do
whatever they want
to demonstrate let's remotely turn off
the victim computer
but this harmless command is just the
tip of the iceberg this same method can
be used to access any of the victim's
files and if a hacker gets access to a
corporate PC they can end up getting
access to what's on the internal Network
and in turn steel or even destroy it for
instance here's how the hacker executes
proxies and opens VPN tunnels in the
corporate Network through the victim's
computer
[Music]
attacks targeting Wireless hid devices
mouses and keyboards are perhaps the
most entertaining and dangerous of our
time enabling access to a victim's
computer in just seconds
since these attacks use radio channels
and remote commands there's no need to
guess passwords or anything like that
its rce right off the bat
[Music]
foreign
Ty that's hiding in plain sight it's an
excellent example of how you and your
company can easily fall victim to a hack
security analysis reveals that despite
the fact that this vulnerability was
found back in 2016. few people actually
know about it and even those who know
greatly underestimate it
nevertheless this vulnerability can
still be found even at big companies and
given the operational specifics of this
vulnerability it's bound to be around
for a long time to come because after
all we don't change our wireless
keyboards and mouses as often as we do
our phones to protect yourselves do the
following check if your devices have
this vulnerability we've added a link to
a full list in the description if it
does see if there are any updates for
your mouse keyboard or USB adapter that
get rid of the mouse Jack problem if
there is no such update then we'd
recommend changing your wireless mouse
keyboard or USB Jack altogether in favor
of one that doesn't have this
vulnerability but even this doesn't
guarantee 100 security since any
wireless device can be hacked so ideally
you'd want to switch back to the classic
corded Mouse if of course going back in
time doesn't scare you too much only
wired devices can give you a 100
guarantee that you won't be hacked this
way and this is worth thinking about if
your computer actually has sensitive
information on it which can be subject
to an attack we at samsub hope that none
of this can ever happen so watch our
upcoming videos where we'll certainly
touch on remote control attacks once
again I'm will try our best to give you
real world advice to keep you safe in
the online jungle until next time
foreign